annie and i are stand-up comedians and
we are on tour and this week i am in
minneapolis i believe it's tomorrow and
then on friday i'm in chicago get
tickets now at estranis.com hello my
people i am so sorry i had to cancel
these past few weekends i am now back on
the road you can see me next in omaha at
the funny bone may 20th through 21st st
louis missouri june 3rd and 4th
houston texas
june 10th through 12th burbank in town
flappers comedy june 18th west niacc in
new york then you can look up other
dates i'll be in austin texas
springfield missouri pennsylvania tempe
arizona colusa california a bunch of
other places please look that up on
andyletterman.com
[Music]
what's going on there's medical news i
don't know
there's medical news i i tried to keep
it away from nurse khalil as long as i
could well it was a it was a combo
situation
okay
what is going on i would just say
there's two things battling inside me
that cannot go together okay one is
is just the worst constipation i've ever
had in my life since i started taking
the hormones it's just been since i
started doing the egg freezing stuff
just severe constipation
now when you're constipated what do you
do you push right yeah however i found
out in after eight hours in the
emergency room
that
in the place of where the eggs are are
now cysts
and i
ruptured a cyst pushing
i fell off the toilet
i was
i was pushing on the toilet
okay i was squeezing i was
i was squeezing on the toilet the other
day i was about to leave for san jose
was there an ego death
there was a there was an ego death and
then there were several in the emergency
room when i when you hear who i was put
next to
it was wild what happened okay so
um i didn't know what it was but all of
a sudden i'm trying to take a [ __ ] and
then i just severe pain in my lower
stomach
um
sweating
um my eyes went crossed i started to
fall off the toilet like i almost
[ __ ] elvis very elephant i almost
elvis of course jealous smaller tits
five pounds lighter and bigger bigger
ass huger ass
uh better career and um
so and then i was just in so much i
didn't know what to do i've never felt
this way it was just like my whole body
felt like it had gone to sleep like
those sort of tingles it was just very
very weird and so i was looking it up um
in excruciating pain todd kept trying to
like straighten my legs and everything
hurt i just was like i'm supposed to go
on an airplane in two hours
so by the way also i just got a spray
tan because i was about to do my promo
for my florida weekend and i was going
to do a whole spray tan thing i was
about to say your tan looks really nice
too can i just tell you there's the last
time you got the best every time you got
covered every time i get a spray tan i'm
i'm hospitaled up
being in a hospital bed in a spray dance
so fine
they're like ma'am you're excreting some
sort of i'm like it's don't worry it's
still not diarrhea
um
but so todd's like we have to go to the
house because that was like there was
nothing to do so we go to the hospital
and it takes for i'm like about to pass
out they put like the ekg things on me
they're like testing my heart and stuff
i'm like if this ends up being no way
but how embarrassing would it be if i
just was constipated i was just from
having to take a [ __ ] you don't think
that's happened to me i've had
mris where they're like it's just a fart
yeah i was like this is just so sorry
but i have to take a [ __ ] i'm [ __ ]
down i remember that six years ago
whenever long you got i think a cat scan
or something i got a cat scan yeah and
they were like yeah you just are filled
with gas and it was because of a really
big dinner i had with benji
at like i don't want to say it but
benji's always i know benji's not benign
let's just say that okay
and she's at the root of it all always
it was so embarrassing okay keep going
did they give you then when you rubbed
your juices they gave you more money
they gave me morphine oh my god it's
gonna
sort of help the pain because it wasn't
that type of pain yeah but it's not
gonna help your constipation no no no no
so now i'm in a hell that i don't even
josh potter so i told you i think last
week that i took josh potter the day
after i got my eggs out i took him to
the hospital we were just like passing
the baton because he was getting a giant
cyst removed from his back so he's
constipated he's like annie i was on the
toilet i took my first [ __ ] into the
thing and i was crying i was like am i
your match because i also wept on a
toilet today too sir
it's just so okay so wait side note
because i feel like people either tend
to run
towards constipation or towards diarrhea
and i feel like you're typically more
diarrhea person and i always say that's
the sweetest thing
i almost kissed your mouth i'm so
jealous of the diarrhea people because
being exploded is so terrible now i
don't take pain pills like doctors never
need to worry about me abusing any sort
of but now that you've felt constipation
do you think would you what do you
prefer i'm like so flattered do you
think i i've had ibs which is both i
mean my whole life yeah when i was a kid
i was constipated my parents used to
yank me out of the glass i'd also like
to add the unfortunate thing about being
a diarrhea girl is that you one would
think it would make you skinny but
because of all the inflammation that's
happening in my gut because of my
colitis i have diarrhea but i'm still
bloated it's like there's no really yeah
it's inflamed oh that's cruel and my
joints are pretty hard to brag about
being a diarrhea person in front of us
right when we just really bloated
diarrhea person with joint pain it's so
bad it's never just it's when i get like
a colitis flare-up it's never just this
the fatigue
yeah the colitis it's the joint pain my
hips hurt real bad it's like a whole
thing but get back to your yeah
so okay just dying in the okay they put
me they put me it took a while to get a
bed
so it's just like totally overwhelmed i
was at cedar cyanide in venice i don't
know if it's venice or marina del ray or
something but so i went there and um
i finally got a bed next to one of the
crazier people that has ever existed on
the earth and it was also right by the
exit so everyone was going in and out
so this guy kept waking up from his nap
like every two minutes we're like can
you guys [ __ ] knock this guy the [ __ ]
out and he was like there's a urethra in
my somebody put a camera in my urethra
and all this stuff where i'm like i'm
about to put my fist in your throat shut
the [ __ ] up he's talking about his dick
camera just being so crazy i'm just like
looking at the nurses like you are
actual heroes like to put up with like
and they're all so calm there's like the
craziest person they've heard at all but
i'm like the i call the cops on these
people if these people show up on my
shows they're done
if you were a nurse you'd call the
police
the police
but then there was a guy outside that
hit a woman there's like a the
firefighter had firefighters had him
outside and then he was getting arrested
for hitting a woman there was a woman in
her like rocking autistic kid i don't
know what was going on there then there
was um a gurney came in they go
it's like because there's the emergency
store a gurney comes in and i'm just
watching someone pass away i mean i just
watched someone die no they put up like
a
a barrier thing but it was not it
covered this much and the body was this
long and i watched it die i got there
was i go oh okay it was alive on this
part i got a time off and then it was
dead on this part
yes and then they go is that true i
swear in my life and then they go
they go um
can't they over their last words someone
can someone get gurney or can someone
get bed one to the morgue i was bed four
i'm like where's bed one
so two people died i was like would you
assume i guess enough but these what are
these people's lives why did you almost
do this it was so crazy
um so then um i had to get like a ct
scan they call over the loud speakers
yeah somebody has to go to because it's
not because it's nothing to them
it's nothing to them
it's this is their lives my best friends
are er nurses it's crazy also i thought
you were going to say my best friends
are in the morgue
some of them my people in bed
um but you know the the horrible thing
about having friends in the medical
field it's not an upside because they've
seen it all so i'm like hey i have this
like weird mole they they're like let's
shut up yeah because they're in the er
all day they're getting really really
extreme cases right and so when i tell
them like my little ailments they're
they're just not listening do you ever
tell them our ailments
just
rise out of them get a little giggle
[Laughter]
but did you ever tell them about
esther's neck muscles
wait so annie um so they gave you more
so this whole time and then finally my
doctor my egg doctor was able to get
back because you know he was in
surgeries all day or whatever and so he
gets back to me goes oh yeah you
probably ruptured a cyst i'm like i
ruptured a cyst and then he was like
yeah all of those are cis so now i mean
i'm constipated and the scared us to
push so now i have 23 cysts left yeah
wait so that's a fact like when you get
your eggs out it becomes a cyst i am
learning as we go i know as much as you
no [ __ ] clue
and so um but the whole thing was crazy
josh is like facetiming he's all [ __ ]
up i'm like all [ __ ] up
uh the guys scream in the background
they let todd in thank god which i think
would also happen oh when they were
taking me to get the x-rays and
everything in the ultrasound
oh and i test pregnant you test pregnant
so then they're like ma'am you're
pregnant i'm like i'm not pregnant i'm
just
uh privileged and i got a trigger shot
that made me seem pregnant and so the
guy pushing me was a schultz fan
and um he's like uh because i was trying
to get in a room i was like comedian you
guys it didn't work yeah um i was like
are you guys do you want your joke no
okay um but the guy pushed me was like
yeah i love andrew schultz and then he
started telling me i don't know how he
got up but he was like i cheated on all
my tests in school i'm like you're my
nurse
oh wait you're my nurse oh i probably
shouldn't out an entire um um
nurse but look
i cheated yes most of i won't say
nursing but most of my other like when i
by the time i got to physics 3 yeah do
you not think i was fully cheating [ __ ]
yeah i was listen in college they gave
me because i have add they gave me like
you could go to the
what was it the center for academic
excellence was like where you would go
take your test you don't have to take
your test in class
so i would just be in a room just
cheating on a test and then my my sats
at my high school
i was allowed to have them untimed
and um
they just left me in a room yeah and i
just
like i didn't cheat because there were
no phones or anything then
sorry i'm not as young as you think i am
it's a spray tan but i didn't have you
know i had a flip flop at a beeper at
that point so i couldn't cheat but i did
just take naps and stuff i just slept i
love that i think i got some of that
treatment when i broke a finger so i was
in a cast for a while and i remember
taking a higher i hated physics i just
hated physics i was taking a higher
physics class when i still want to
become a doctor you guys you wanted to
become a doctor yeah this is my first
dream kaleido let's do it i'll send you
to me
let's have sex
if you want to be a doctor i'll let you
dress up like a doctor and i'll
obviously be the patient because look at
my sickly body
that's one of the sweeter things dr drew
um said to me he's like i really think
you should pursue that i think you have
the brain for that you do oh thank you
that's so sweet it never happens i know
why are you wasting your life on these
podcasts losers
you should be anything other than what
i'm doing except you should be not here
i let her have my teachers you should go
no my teacher's like you should do stand
up or something get out of here because
i was always just i thought it was funny
to disrupt a class and they're like
people are trying to learn they paid for
this it was college did you ever cheat
in high school
um
my whole strategy in high school was
like i feel like i i realized i'm not
going to be a straight a student that
takes too much effort i was like i'm
going to put in the least amount of work
where i can still get a decent grade so
i was like what's decent b i was like
i'm going to get easy b's was kind of my
strategy i always thought i'd get easy
bees never happened
now i wish i would have gotten a c now
your parents would not have cared if you
were straight a student right would it
have not been no so that's why there's
this is on education i don't know
yeah were you what were you saying i
feel like i i forgot but the rule in my
house is like b minus in and and up for
jules and up yeah it's like you know
it's too much money at stake it's
expensive see you're slacking off like
see you're slacking off yeah yeah like
it's like you're either your attendance
is bad like just just try a little bit i
don't need a plus but i was pushed i was
a plus student
most of my life
and um as soon as i had a little bit of
freedom i became
a straight f student really yeah because
you just get so tired of being pushed in
the expectation you're just you're just
so burned out of being a young prodigy
but also like they expected excellence
from you so maybe the way you got
attention was to not be excellent yeah i
think that i honestly i felt like an old
person by the time i was like 15. i'm
tired can i just sleep yeah i remember
thinking when i turn 18 and i have some
autonomy i'm just going to sleep all day
you should have gone to my high school
they let us we could take naps you could
leave school
high school because they wanted free
skills they were like they're like oh
get them in bed take a nap little kids
come on sleep sleep sleep stay on
pillows instead of chairs these are the
[ __ ] you on
in
i offered to digitally disempower i know
todd i almost had todd do it but i will
tell you what that is an option for you
too little one on your hard constipation
day i almost you gotta learn to get
constipated what did you do where are
you diarrhea girl no i'm kind of what do
you think well then what what do you
think digital means like you're going to
put your face yeah my digits swirl it
around i need it
in life does it work yeah because a lot
of people um
who are for instance like
wheelchair-bound or have lost the
ability to they've lost their like
mcturition their reflexes
sounds like the rib
to poor pee
um they need assistance right and one of
the ways to assist someone to poo is to
digitally disassemble i would do that to
either of you guys if that happened
would you what about like should she
squirt water up there like an enema
i'm working i've worked some some magic
moves i did have to cancel i'm so sorry
i had to cancel these weekends you guys
i did not my agent is funny my agent
said when i told him i was going to do
the egg stuff he goes you're not going
to be able to perform how did he know i
was like because he has other
other
female comics yeah and i was like no i
think i can do it i think i can do it
and it's just not the comfortable that
the discomfort that i was told i was
going to have is it does not work with
traveling and doing stand-up it's not
like if it was like spots at the comedy
store i'd probably be able to do it but
it's just and hormonally i think the
hormones are like just leaving my body
now he said in the next couple days so
i'm feeling like good again yeah and
it's also catch 22 cause like you just
you know
yeah
everything that's happened the ruptured
cysts and then having to take medication
to deal with their uptrend and now
they're not pooing but so they gave you
collates that didn't work okay and
you're relaxed
but then i miralax takes three days i
don't i didn't this was not three day
this was like i need like a [ __ ]
c-section are you allowed to take um
supplements like magnesium
i already i take magnesium every day i
think i would up the magnesium yeah i
take a lot of by the way can i keep
taking uh prenatal vitamins they make me
look so pretty they i think everyone can
take
it's the favorite
acid so your baby doesn't get spina
bifida literally the most is that right
pete
i have no idea that's so funny how
confident she was that you didn't know
that i for some reason think that pete
is like the most like responsible dad he
would know all of this she's like we
look over peter spina bifida
he's like i have a tail [ __ ] haven't
you seen have a hairy tail i used to
work with because of spina bifida love
my spina bifida kids you guys are the
best i love those kitties but anyway
kids with spina bifida you know okay
it's not spina bifida anyway
i'm just throwing off that you
used to have a pager
you didn't get a pager no and now i
[ __ ] want one and i'll give you a
pager i was poor and i had a pager can
the three of us that's like goes with
poor people
pagers were like every person has a very
poor person i feel like we bring pagers
back i feel like that's really how we do
all our business communication is on our
god another way for you guys to not
respond to me
wait but only for speaking do you guys
know how to write in numbers
because i do i'm a [ __ ] wiz i just
know one for three
annie is nine
um
one seven one seven
one three that's annie
you are looking quite asian right now
i'm not trying to be racist but you guys
did not write full sentences on pagers
and gorgeous did you even have the
motorola you had one piece i didn't i
wanted one real bad never guys i don't
want to brag but i did have a pager and
it was baby blue jelly this is clear
mine was um mine was green jelly and it
was a motorola because we didn't have
girl colors wait you had jelly ones what
color would yours have been i think blue
jelly sounds like yeah copying me yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
the next day yeah yeah
um
yeah
what was i gonna say oh i got an f in
racquetball in college
i got an f in racquetball in college i
thought i was going to be able to just
talk my way out of that one
and the lady was like no [ __ ]
she's like you didn't jump to any of the
classes like my elbow hurt she's like
[ __ ] you
i got i did the opposite i got out of an
entire elective course that was like pe
in college i'm like who the [ __ ] needs
to be in college but it was one of the
final courses i had to take but the
first day i was like look if i do like
50 push-ups do i need to come here every
week she's like no you look like you
could and i did 50 push-ups in front of
her and i never had to show up again i'm
like i'm fit i work out at home
i don't need to be here for this i don't
know you could negotiate with the
children you don't know you can
negotiate with all of them i okay my art
teacher my um college art professor
i it was my painting class i did three
paintings okay i went never went to
class i never went to the critiques i
did three paintings one was of a it was
the assignment was to do something in
black and white and i did a
um cube ice cube tray and it was [ __ ]
good okay it was very hard i picked a
hard object so i impressed him with that
i did two self-portraits and um and i
did nothing else but i was friends with
the teacher i used to babysit his kids
and stuff and he came would come into my
restaurant all the time so i we're like
coming to the grade time i go i realized
like there's no i always thought like
i'll make it up at the end and then it
was the end and then i was like
[ __ ] so i go in and i'm like um
i'm like hey uh can you just like just
hook me up with like a b or an
incomplete or something just give me a b
just hook it up with the b and goes
he's like annie you showed up to none of
the things you didn't show up to one
critique i cannot give you a b and i go
i'm so sorry when you show up to my
restaurant and i give your family free
food did you earn the free food oh my
god did you earn it or did i just hook
you up with the food and he goes all
right you don't tell anyone
he's my friend that did not work for me
so i took a whole year of ocam organic
chemistry and like my second semester of
ocam ocam sounds some like something
very different
like your orgasm camera your webcam girl
well i i tried so hard my my professor
shout out to um his name is professor
marlon he was so good and so great and
he did his job excellently but you know
i just was not very i wasn't a very
diligent student at this time so i was
kind of like half-assing the course but
we talked so much about mma he was a he
did jiu jitsu he was and i just admired
that gave me points and i was in my head
i was like i don't need to try that hard
in this class i can't just synthesize
these [ __ ] things all day
and i really thought i had an in
and by the time the semester was over i
got a c plus and i felt super betrayed
but i really respect them for giving me
that c-plus
like when you [ __ ] up on so many classes
like you come to really accept the
c-plus
you go you know what thank you so much
for that cpas
because you don't have to retake the
class or anything yeah i had one teacher
uh
a teacher in college who
um used my it was my writing teacher we
had to write we had to take an object
and write like a story about the object
i took this this polaroid about my
grandfather and i wrote this whole story
about my grandfather's death and which
is so funny to like i mean no offense i
was gonna say like crying about your
grandparents dying when people's parents
are dead anyway
but i wrote this thing and um
he i never went to class after that i
would always do one really good thing
he used it as the example for all his
classes he didn't tell me this till
later he gave me like a c minus and i
think i didn't have to retake the class
but then he came into my restaurant
and i didn't own the restaurant i just
was very loud and drunk so it felt like
mine
but um so he
he came in and i was like oh my god you
gave me a [ __ ] c minus he goes but i
use i give your thing out as an example
to all the kids and i go okay not really
the credit i was looking for but thank
you dude that's what my step-dad did to
me he gave me a [ __ ] f
was your teacher he was my high school
history teacher your current stepdad
yeah roger he gave me an did you call
him roger and he was like i have to give
you enough you keep calling me roger
yeah he gave me an hour maybe it was her
father was he trying to get oh thank you
solving all of our childhood trolls but
also that's like was he just like trying
to get so that your mom would have to
come get involved well he he
i wish i hadn't told him
he hated procrastinators and he hated
that i was um the class for me was easy
i was getting like straight a's all well
his class i was getting a's um and he
was just like he i told him i was like
yup did all of that last night he knew
that i had procrastinated and it wasn't
he graded me not for what the criteria
was for but based on what he knew i
could have done but what i actually
under-delivered
and he was like this is a lesson for you
you didn't try it's like it looks great
it's possible but it's it's not up to
what i said oh my god he's so one of
your parents i'm like
a parent is that such good parenting i'm
like [ __ ] you're already my dad i guess
it's advanced parenting
no one would dare parent me on that
level give you an f no way like you're
screaming reason and a care behind it
i'm i'm surprised to hear that in
college you guys didn't go to class
because to me i'm like
college is so expensive
how i
never missed class and in fact like it
wasn't until i started hating it and
thinking it was so stupid when i was
like
this costs money i'm out of here like
i'm quitting because it's so i was so
focused on the cost of college
i um no i got a full ride at first so i
didn't have to because i was an athlete
but when i got out of there i went to
community college which was affordable
you stupid [ __ ] yeah
and then community community community
and then back to um cal state long beach
but but you're right by the time i got
to cal state long beach nursing school
yeah i made sure i didn't fail out of
every class i tried i tried to do that
like where i broke it down by how much
like how many hours how much it cost per
hour because i thought maybe that would
work to get me to go to class but i just
don't like being told what to do yeah i
just i think there's a word for that it
wasn't i have that it's called demand
avoidance is it demand avoidance
it's probably the same thing it's when
people tell me i have to do something
where i'm like oh that's it you're never
especially in art class and stuff like
that used to always bother me because i
was like demand avoidance involves not
being able to do certain things at
certain times either for yourself or
others and also refers to the things we
do in order to avoid demands it's
actually one of the some a trait of
people on the spectrum sometimes it can
be
that makes sense i kind of relate to
that like i feel like
sometimes like if dave is like
can you unload the dishwasher today i'm
like
i'll do it tomorrow [ __ ]
sometimes these girls you're friends
with
ignore you they look at your phone their
phones they forget they're at work they
don't care about you
and it gets to you it hurts your
feelings
so that's when you go to betterhelp.com
trash tuesday
you guys we've had
uh
pretty um
exhausting last couple months yeah
mentally tax things yeah what did you
say yeah
and this podcast is sponsored by better
help online therapy because life can be
overwhelming and many people are burned
out without even knowing it symptoms can
include lack of motivation feeling
helpless or trapped attachment fatigue
and more we all have that by the way um
for me it's a feeling of am i living in
reality
this this is what's happening
really happening
and this is why we usually think that
burnout is
solely associated with
work in our case it is
you guys better help is customized
online therapy that offers video phone
and even live chat sessions with your
therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to by
the way including us you could turn this
off at any time if you don't want to see
us it's more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours this podcast
is sponsored by better help and trash
tuesday listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com trash tuesday
annie can you spell that b e t t e r h e
l p she did it you guys do you know how
full that better help journal is for me
there's there's only so much i can write
that whole thing is like i've used up
every single character
written in blood and that's
betterhelp.com
trash tuesday let's talk about truebill
truebill is the new app that helps you
identify and stop paying for
subscriptions that you don't want or
need or simply forgot about and this
beast over here has saved so much money
using true bill it makes spend it
immediately
it makes me uncomfortable you guys on
average people um save 720
a year from true bill that's a lot guys
sign up for more things this is pathetic
it's because companies make
subscriptions hard to cancel and true
bill makes it incredibly simple just
link your accounts and drupal will
cancel your unwanted subscriptions in
one tap
i didn't know i was subscribed to an
insect finder app i didn't know i was
subscribed to an anime app that my um
young niece had okay i think those
things either and i'm not okay with the
fact that you had those i had a plant
app where you like put it on like the
bad part of the plan yeah yeah and my
plants have been dead for so long that i
can't like there's nothing left to fix
true bill has over 2 million users and
has helped save them over 100 million
dollars
um we love trubil here because we're not
always on top of everything so we need a
little help you guys don't fall for
subscription scams start canceling today
at
truebill.com trash tuesday and your true
will concierge is there when you need
them to cancel unwanted subscriptions so
you don't have to go right now
truebill.com trash tuesday it could save
you thousands a year truebill.com
trash tuesday
wait i know we're going all over the
place but i'm dying to ask you something
um you had job on tiger belly yesterday
can you please tell me wow that's the
first time we've heard his name on this
podcast ever it's ever been brought up
but can you tell us what happened i want
to be like super
like kind about this whole thing because
i think it does it did take a lot for
him to sit in front of us
um i
i gotta tell you probably one of
the most boring episodes we've ever done
only because it's like there was hardly
any laughs it was so tense it was very
uncomfortable
and um
i didn't
i wish that
i i was going in there thinking that he
would just like
take responsibility for everything but
there was one piece of information that
i felt like i still have a big like
mistrust for him so we have a long way
to go really even after you had him on
yeah and we talked about it on the show
i think like you know i don't have any
ill feeling towards him anymore but
there's still a lot of mistrust and only
because you know i he's still not
willing to admit that
um what we said on the show ultimately
led to the whole spectacle
that became the reddit accusation he's
saying those are two different
occurrences but i'm like
the timing is very strange because it
was only a couple days after our live
show that the the the reddit accusations
came out and the slandering came out so
we're not there yet i think that we have
a long way to go before like we fully
like
have some type of
uh i don't know like goodness between us
but i do respect that
you know
i appreciate that he had the balls to
come on the show okay but can you tell
me then like what did come out of it
like what did he own up to i wish he had
the balls to come on this show because i
still after hearing um
him talk to
everyone except me about it i realized i
did misinterpreted it
and i
when he i watched the did you watch the
fighter in the kid i did not i don't
want to well i you know i didn't realize
he was being so bullied that he was
afraid for his life is what he was
saying and i guess when he asked me to
walk into the truck he wasn't
wanting to do sexual favors i'm so
embarrassed by that but he needed like
an escort because he was scared that the
haters were going to come
and i actually guys i actually made a
petition to not be mean on the internet
anymore that says petition to no b
wrong i think we should know be mean on
the internet i have stickers there's
different colors you can use no more
mean on the internet especially to these
good guys because
they are just trying to fight for
freedom of speech and so if you say mean
things about them i'm going to make sure
this gets to elon musk and we're going
to stop this right now
so
if anybody wants to sign it i've got
different colored crayons and stickers
you can choose from your favorite
colors sorry but i have to ask so
i'm just curious so they
they're scared yes it was because they
were bullied that they were able to
bully others oh because they were being
bullied and i misinterpreted it and i am
do i put like listen i know it's going
to take a while but i hope you do
forgive me
and i hope we can move on i have
lit nothing for love but you and
yes so i misinterpreted it's
i did ask him i said brendan i was like
you gotta come on our show like you've
got to i think you've got to talk to
annie this is what he said he's like
kyla just please not this week
i didn't know they were victims of this
this mean bullying online and it was
affecting them so much and i'm so sorry
to contribute to that and that's why
this petition will be sent to elon musk
i am so sorry
that this happened to them that they
were so scared that they had to commit a
fight i know comedy is hard
you just didn't you just signed with a
heart yeah i'm just sending love pete
did you want to sign criminals i think
you should pass this on to the crew
[Music]
no more bullying behind the scenes you
guys do you hear me
delilah no more bullying behind the
scenes no more calling and threatening
it's just i will continue to tell
stories i want i have no interest in me
tooing anyone nobody did anything wrong
i don't care if anyone hits on me i
really don't even care if anyone hits me
that wasn't the point i was making a
point anonymously if i wanted the clicks
for it and the drama i would have said
the person's name i still am not saying
their name um because this was not my
intention at all but i am allowed to
tell a story that's interesting to me
and i think is like relatable and to any
woman in a workplace yes well here's
what i'll say about that guy or girl and
it's it's like
if you're not if if it's not true
and you didn't read the comments
how would you know
that it's you and why did you say it to
you what do you guys have to say about
the fact that like the way i saw him and
the way that
like he comes off to me
he seems just
genuinely broken by the internet like
this is somebody who is really like a
parent like i i don't want to put out
like i don't buy it either because we
all get [ __ ] kala literally i read the
comments you guys last night bomb
threats at his shows
bomb threat do you think they're gonna
buy i have to have i have lists of men
that aren't allowed at my show because
they're threatening to kill me all the
time do you understand like people this
is what goes with the show people who
think that like oh we got we got one
over on everybody because we told this
story we're now being harassed
everything i post online i'm harassed
about these like walk me to my channel
why they wouldn't want to [ __ ] you
by the way i know that by the way if
those people that we're talking about
watch this show nothing i say will be
heard because i'm ugly to them
oh my god here's what i do i will say
you know
if my
dog was behaving badly
um
i can see how someone would call me
and be like get your dog in line right
but you are not a dog yeah i
have said since the beginning anyone
talking to me about this offline
i never said this person's name i'm
never going to say their name i was that
was never my intention
he can call me i said that over and over
again he can call me but instead it had
to be this whole thing behind the scenes
bullying behind the scenes i did tell
him that i think i think your best move
here is to
call in but i'm just gonna say this i'm
taking the truck out of auto park i'm
putting it neutral i'm letting it slide
down the hill i'm done talking about it
it's all good but listen guys if we zoom
out a little bit
on
everything on our lives
like
this is a joke this doesn't matter yeah
it's an anonymous anecdote it's still
always just not matter like and what i
find interesting in all of this is that
you know the players involved the little
game a telephone that has been the
people involved outside of the three of
us the people in between who are
they're all
having
this is high entertainment for them
including our friends and colleagues who
are like what's happening oh no but he
said this all of them think this is
a dumpster fire they cannot peel their
eyes away from so we have to see it as
you know for me it's felt like a
lose-lose only because it's like
like everyone's just laughing at this
whole spectacle it turned into seems
like a win me that's what i go for his
life
i just you tell jokes but it's like it
was you know and that's what i tried to
convey to him like as honestly as i
could it's like brendan this was
something so small on january 25th
there was we had a giggly little girl
talk on january 26th a phone call could
have been made to say that hurt my
feelings can you guys not do that
anymore instead now there's federal
possibly federal crimes so to me that's
an absurdity that i cannot wrap my head
around and i'd like to officially say i
am exiting this
[ __ ] circus yeah i think that
you know we we work in this field of
people most of them in our are clowns in
arrested development and and maybe
that's me too
but this clown is leaving the [ __ ]
circus i'm out
i'm out it's not worth it you guys we
have a great show you know we got it it
we didn't mean to hurt anyone then we
were told we were intentionally hurting
someone when we never there's right it's
done it's done and people's personal
lives are not our best i don't care i
don't give a [ __ ] we don't care you guys
do what you do
it's been
i mean it went to the top let's just say
that
this whole situation this small little
podcast operation
one minute of little girl talk you know
it just went all the way to the girl
[ __ ]
i was doing big girl talk oh kyle she's
right here oh my god that's so mean
she's the little girl
as brennan schaub would say it's water
under the rug
but brendan it's your move
well we're done come to the show come
hang out with us yeah so i also wanted
to clarify for the audience that watched
a tiger belly episode that schaub said
that he had like 300 pages of evidence
against us but then it was never shown
to us or our production team even though
i had continued to ask for it right um
but at the end of the show he was like i
will show you after the show but i'm
like well my audience is not gonna know
what we've seen
so i'm
putting this information on trash
tuesday instead what we saw was a very
zoomed in photo of
html codes
numbers no context on a paper and you
know when you encircle
something on your phone with red
it just said the company's email
and then he showed me another page all
html code no context completely zoomed
in and it said robert lee which is not
even bobby's like government name
um and that was the president
yeah robert e lee it was robert e henry
or like a general evil
i can't believe you had government
officials coming after him already so i
know that's so [ __ ] up i was supposed
to update the uh we were supposed to
update the audience and tiger belly but
we forgot
um but those are two things that i saw
and i was like brendan this is
a joke this is a mickey mouse like
someone could have just
sent you this my mom could have just
photoshopped this um so if it was your
mom i'm giving him i'm giving him
it probably was i'm giving him the
benefit of the doubt however and i am
his team is now working with um my
production because to me when i saw it i
was like
i like with all due respect brandon but
this
cannot be real like this is a joke and
he was like well so we're still working
and don't be mean about it because we
did make a no no mean i was not shown
anything
uh of substantial or anything that would
even match his accusation towards our
company so that's what i want to say out
there that's the truth that's a that is
the truth i wanted to put up as someone
who knows that bobby doesn't know how to
buy a computer
i
that's checks out for me bobby doesn't
know how to check his email
like he doesn't know how to even log on
to his email
he i i don't think he can text barely
barely he better not be able to
know me a few okay
[Laughter]
okay
i can't believe this but all three of us
take neutrophil every day yes four pills
a day every single day like we're all
actually dedicated and agree on this one
thing it's so good isn't it amazing when
something actually works
it makes me so happy there's extra
little vitamins in there i feel healthy
i'm excited all natural ingredients yeah
there's no downsides yeah and it's not
they're not claiming to be an overnight
fix you know we just take the
recommended dose every day and i swear
in a couple of months guys your baby
hairs will be adult hairs my baby hairs
are like in middle school you guys this
is crazy they have uh women's formula
and men's formula i i think all of our
partners take it too
but like kala said healthier hair growth
takes time and you'll begin to
experience thicker stronger faster
growing hair in three to six months like
she said not an overnight fix this is
the real deal we're in a lifelong
committed relationship and it's not just
the powerful ingredients also will bring
your body back into balance you may also
notice improvements in your overall
well-being including more restful sleep
less stress and better skin nails and
libido babies yes about the nails oh
yeah yes about the nails i have the
weakest nails you guys but since neutral
i've been able to get
you know gel manicures again not
currently but you know what i mean like
sometimes your nails get really worn out
by doing a lot of you know acrylics girl
stuff
with neutral it really helps me support
that
you can grow thicker healthier hair and
support our show by going to
nutrafull.com
trash to save 15 off your first month
subscription this is their best offer
anywhere and it is only available to us
customers for a limited time plus free
shipping on every order get fifteen
dollars off at nutrifield.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l dot com slash trash this
is our hair secret it can be yours too
we love magic spoon we all eat it i
don't even know what else to say it's so
good it's like the greatest cheat code
to life yeah i have a boyfriend who's so
young and still a pig and can just eat
all of the regular cereals and now i
don't have to feel left out and
miserable i get to eat a delicious
healthy alternative and one day he's
going to have to turn to magic spoons
you guys i'm super sensitive to certain
grains um i try to keep a very low grain
almost grain free diet um because i have
digestive issues and magic spoon is
such a relief to have in the home
because i love cereal and why would i
have to give that up just because i
would have to give it the joys of cereal
just because
i have digestive issues i know you know
before magic spoon i never like i feel
like 10 years went by where i never got
to just indulge in cereal because i felt
too guilty or it didn't make me feel
good so the fact that now i have that
option like i go home i see it in my
kitchen i'm like if i get my cravings
after my set tonight i can have that and
not feel like s-h-i-t the next day and
also my mom makes treats out of them
say that we should eat some of those we
should bring some of those in they're so
good you guys it's very important to
note that they have zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net grams of carbs in each serving
but the honey nut flavor has one gram of
sugar it's keto friendly gluten free
grain free soy free and low carb and we
all have our favorite flavors mine is
fruity annie says cookies and cream i'm
a classic frosted kind of girl um
we highly encourage you to build your
own box try all of our favorite flavors
and you guys can go to magicspoon.com
tuesday to grab a custom bundle of
cereal and be sure to use our promo code
tuesday at checkout to save five dollars
off your order and magic spoon is so
confident in their product it's backed
with a 100 happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund your money no questions asked why
wouldn't you order it's so good how many
times have you returned an empty box
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
tuesday and use the code tuesday to save
five dollars off thank you magic spoon
for sponsoring this episode you gotta
admit we're a good fit for you we love
you and you love us we love you we want
to spoon you magically
[Music]
can i tell you how i helped my poop oh
yeah
so okay so when i called your doctor i
go look because he was like just wait a
couple days i was like i don't have a
couple days i was like i am so sorry if
this seems dramatic i had to cancel two
weeks i'm missing out on thousands of
thousands of dollars by the way i'm
missing out on seeing my fans i want to
see them i don't want to keep it's not
dramatic dude bowel issues are
you know like those will derail your
entire entire week he goes can you take
a suppositor i go doc last time i took
his depository i fell off the toilet it
goes oh god don't do it he goes you're
right you can't strain you could pop
another one
you didn't say pop you said it
clinically so you're not going to take
just a suppository opinion it doesn't it
didn't la when i tried that's when i did
that's the passing out that was what
happened it was me it wasn't working
because it was so hard sorry you are
putting not to give up boners this is a
boner warning if you're with your wives
maybe have them leave the room we know
you're about to get really hard can i
ask you something
how did you administer this depository
and were you doing it and in just a
really savage way that you caused
yourself to pass out
no no no it wasn't the insertion it was
inserting it and then it didn't work it
didn't break it up enough yeah because i
think it might have been like esther's
head size like it was like
i was like i it was like ass birth it
was crazy and i needed an episiotomy and
it was not coming
and i was just and then it popped it
ruptured the cyst and then that was they
thought it was appendicitis i was in the
hospital for eight
hours oh lord and um it was we had a
good time i always have a good time so
it was fine but
then uh
so then i called the doctor yesterday i
go look i got it todd was like i'm
booking you a
colon
what do you call them
he's like i'm booking you a colonic and
i was like well let me i don't want to
rupture another thing so i call the
doctor goes you can get one i go thank
you so much did you do it yet i did it
yesterday i have another one today which
i i don't think you're supposed to get
two but this is can you
tell us everything i can't wait to tell
you about it so you go and she's got
sage she's making it real chill for you
and um
uh she went and todd filmed the whole
thing todd came with me there is
possible content coming but i have to
review it to see if it's too disgusting
we may have to pixelate out some things
but so you go in
she and i was like
i i don't know how explain like it was
insane i was just crying all day i
couldn't walk
so
they flip you on your side and then they
insert this tube into your ass and they
flip you back
and then she like massages your stomach
and it squirts the water up your [ __ ]
fills you up and you're like ah she's
like once it's like too uncomfortable
let me know and then they release it and
then you see like little like
duties little flakes coming out and
different coloring and stuff she was
like when she put it in she goes oh i
can feel it's in
there turd
do you have a friend named esther
and it was just it was so painful but i
knew she was like this is gonna work
you're probably gonna have to come back
again tomorrow
but so she shot out and things were
coming out it would hurt and you would
it was an hour which was massaging and
then um
afterwards you go into the bathroom
on the squatty potty and you get the
rest out and i gave birth and todd was
in there too
and then and then you don't you don't
fart in front of bobby
i've never taken a [ __ ] alone in three
years
but um
then he couldn't get out because there
was a new client
wait that's making me think of how
whenever dave comes near the bathroom
and i'm going number two
i always shout like privacy privacy and
he's like this is why the door closes
you can always close the door we never
ever close the door in my household my
family like
open door bathroom door policy yeah i
mean i i do
like having company when i poo just not
bobby just not my partner yeah
because i think he has a poo fetish what
he likes to inhale my fumes like that's
how todd is he's like i want to see your
mess todd likes all my messages because
he wants it so much i just can't give it
wait when you said todd likes all your
messes he wants to see everything not
your [ __ ] though right
i mean he would like it's he's not like
fetishly looking for it but he would be
like he would take a look would he wipe
you yes he was like i'll stick my finger
up your ass he kept telling me i almost
had him do it i'm leaving
dave for todd you're leaving todd for
dave i'm leaving you here
i don't even know what i'm saying
anymore
i'm so
ignited don't make me laugh i'm gonna
pop assist
do they go away eventually he says i i
don't know why are you looking at me dr
wong is at your disposal i've had i know
we have to get them on because i am
giving such confusing information i
don't know what's happening i'm like
doctor
i've had ovarian cysts
and i've had them one where they rupture
and it's very painful or you just have
them and then the doctors like
will just check and then they're gone
like they kind of just go away on their
own so for the most sometimes they'll
even discharge you and be like it was
probably a cyst that's what happens they
give you a demerol back have you guys
ever squeezed your [ __ ] outside you're
like
like that's how i've been for a week you
probably well yeah because you probably
wiggled out is what happened your vagal
nerve is very yeah it's still up there
though my [ __ ] didn't pop out it's
still up there guys general
advice as a person who leans towards
constipation
you should really get out of the habit
of pushing hard
like
if
this is not happening
you gotta just move on that is my policy
no pushing
yeah it really when when i started
getting teaching she told me that's what
she told me with the tube of my ass too
she was like don't push you're gonna
urge i'm like this feels like lamaze
class like everything was so
birth like
it's basically the same thing right
i just want to say too um sort of
unrelated but i watched you guys on h3h3
and
i
it really i appreciated that bobby
talked about like the way that
women were treated at the comedy store
like 10 years ago and it made me realize
why because i'm always like why do i
feel so connected to bobby why am i so
like undying like just so loyal and
loving towards him and i i kind of put
it together in that moment that when i
showed up 13 years ago
um
every single
older man there either
i'm just thinking about how old they are
elderly some elderly
either
absolutely just didn't look at me right
right like i just didn't exist or
like said something creepy and like
sexual to me or
elderly mouth kissed you no that still
happens so
i get kissed every night on stage um
but
bobby
literally invited me to denny's with the
guys and
treated me like a young comedian and
like did he make you pay wouldn't that
have been for me she's got it he would
just like i just felt like i was in a
club when bobby was there and would take
me out and i i'm like oh my god like he
made me feel included when no other
man there did and i'm like wow that's a
that's crazy that's amazing that he did
that for me i don't know i'm i'm just
like
i think it's cool and
generally i'm just really proud of the
fact that
something similar to what you said which
is like
he's 50. he's like i'm 50. i'm no longer
gonna be
bullied by
he's like i've been around this [ __ ]
business for so long and i'm still
getting this people like to work with
bobby he's respected he has a great
reputation
he's lovely he's just the most lovable
human being i think it's important to
sorry to interrupt you but um
for the first time i'm sorry to
apologize for the first time ever um
but um
i think to learn from how we saw
this other person handling this it's
like a really good time for us to really
really really realize that our people
are going to be our people and
understand us and the other ones are not
and that we cannot
take the criticism to heart because we
just watched someone
make a whole
huge thing out of doing that right and
um
haters gonna hate you know but i am
projecting on to you it's just but i
appreciate you girls so much because you
were aware of to an extent of the
situation with bobby and i
and there was just no judgment you were
like
yeah you guys you know love each other
you do what you have to do to make it
work you're going through a difficult
time
um you know and i really just want to
say like thank you for not being like
[ __ ] or just just being supportive
just be like hey your love is your love
your rules are your rules and i don't
know like from the bottom of my heart i
just want to say like thank you for just
being like always having my daughter
i appreciate you saying that and i mean
this in the best way possible i just
don't care right why would i i'm like i
love bobby i love kalila they're both
like in my life forever i don't give a
[ __ ] like yeah that i don't care yeah i
just don't it's boring to me i don't
care yeah
but i masturbate to it but
but i masturbate to deaf different
scenarios
whatever you give me i like
pete i see green bananas coming my way
they weren't right ones
these
he was looking at the bananas like this
he was like
thank you did you throw did you bruise
them a little on the bottom to kind of
soften them up
did you guys know that carlos has
covered that's why he's not here should
we call
[Music]
hi calling you live from the banana
break
show us your coven are you it's it's
only on the phone sounds like you're out
are you out with
[ __ ] [ __ ]
what's going on
what carlos don't address that a person
you can date it's not a guy
i wore a mask i needed to buy weed
don't smoke it ding dong eat it
you're smoking
and vaping um don't brag and vaping he's
a forever team
yesterday so i'm like
i feel like you're so rich do you feel
alone even rogan couldn't get me those
do you feel better
i feel a little better yesterday was
horrible and today i just feel super
weak but i'm trying to get high and just
chill how do you think you got it
how do you feel like that's different
from the normal life hollywood
saturday night but clubs
any naked people dancing
[Music]
i was thinking that this would be
because you tested positive yesterday
that would be too soon that maybe you
got it from bad friends and friends i
actually think that's when it was oh
i feel like you wanted to be bad friends
and not your show yeah i i that's
correct
this is a marketing ploy pinata andres
does andres have it it was fancy it was
your show fancy we call them fancy see
now fancy coven our show was copy free
completely
they turned away so much coven
we'll see maybe we find out from someone
in the green room that night but anyways
we just wanted to say hi and make sure
that you're okay and can you bring us
better bananas in five minutes the
bananas we would rather get covered
no
they don't even have a label on them
these are brandless
ugh
okay well feel better carlos love you
carlos miss you thank you feel better
you can go to iran get some soup from
iron
arrow one soup what a controversial
issue why so the most delicious that's
all i'm eating i really tried they have
a split pea and mint that i oh that's my
favorite how i love it so much because i
was like who likes oh it's my favorite
i love it so much it's so delicious i
really tried i tried three different
times so i'm like okay this is a complex
combo i'm really trying to get it i
don't like it you can just move on no
because i just think that there are very
few things i dislike i pride myself in
being able to eat it all
and this was one where i was like
i love that soup they haven't had in a
while and i love soups you better not
complain too much much and i got it
taken off the menu
i haven't seen months by the way there's
a new erawan right by
um my spot so have you guys ever gone on
like a california road trip and seen
that big sign that's like stop here for
the world's best split people on the way
to not it's kind of close to harris
ranch it's close to um when you drive on
the five to san francisco yeah yeah it's
anderson's peace peace
yeah
is it like i stopped yeah and of course
i liked it the elderly woman stuff i
liked it too but i was kind of like why
is this a thing it's not well they just
named it that no one named the world
famous comedy store the world famous
comedy store except the owners of the
comedy story right are you saying why
isn't the thing why is pea soup a
roadside attraction in california just
saying it's the best because it's people
like you who would stop it we should
have named this the best podcast
that's that's very george kimmel by the
way his twit his twitter handle is voted
best tweets
that's so lame i'm a soup girl i'll take
any soup pea soup is [ __ ] good what's
your favorite soup
i really on you want to get down you
want to go there
a
pureed
oat broccoli
creamy but dairy-free how could this
keep you constipated
just a thick creamy but knowing that it
has a veggie in it broccoli fake cheddar
yeah when you eat us out do you want us
to put like a carrot in there oh my god
what's your guys's favorite soup um og
chicken noodle soup but i love to
explore and expand um oh also lima bean
lima beans great any bean soup is great
with like bacon how are you constipated
[Laughter]
i don't know i look like most soups
matzo ball soup my girl hey girl we got
my 23andme is making me more jewish by
the way i do like lots of balls about 23
percent cabbage
my favorite soup is um it's kind of it's
called lugao it's very it's like just a
rice porridge but it's kind of like
aroscaldo that's my favorite yeah with
chicken and yeah that's my favorite
todd's mom makes it it's so good it's
really good i love that
hot pot can we go get hot pot hot pot's
the best hot pot is so good yeah we
should go there's good places
hot spot you're a vegetarian yeah it's
like this it's um it's and there's like
a little boiled egg there it's very
that's my favorite yes yes it's very
very very good also egg drop soup i mean
really awesome hot and sour soup
or even just a very simple miso i'll
tell you
my least favorite wonton soup i'll eat
it but for some reason it just never
it never hits me right i wish i got a
different one are we a clam chowder of
course but i'm too i've been lactose
intolerant too long to [ __ ] with them
i'm not there yet i'm i haven't turned
lactose intolerant yet i turned
unlactose intolerant
oxtail soup ooh like fall and stuff like
that obviously very good oh
let's go get soup
ready
i'm getting my ass sucked out again at
four you lucky [ __ ] there's more in
there she goes you need to come back and
go yeah i'm sucked out it was amazing
twins you have twins i wish you could
have seen todd like
todd went through it i have the best
point
todd's the mvp
we should knight him why do i feel like
like the funniest thing possible is for
you to call us two hours later like todd
is missing
he dove into the toilet to chase the
turret
he's like [ __ ] i put her engagement ring
in there
we should really pitch him to be
knighted
we should and also if there's any
diamond places that want to give us a
free ring oh yes let's talk about this
wait a second i think that choosing a
diamond for a woman shouldn't be a solo
no no no no we went and looked we looked
it and he literally the first one he
picked i went i'm so glad i'm here i
would have been he knows i'm gonna be
mad at him if i'm not involved okay so
that's a very uh delicate situation like
guys are not meant to know what we what
jewelry we like right like when the dave
um what kind of ring did you get from
dave and did he recycle who did he get
input from
he um
well keep in mind it was
demanded we were together for
six years before he proposed and i what
was the ultimatum i asked for it like
six months in oh okay so
um
but he had like a family diamond and
then i just said i just
it was a loose diamond i was like i just
want like as plain it's so beautiful i
love that it's the best case scenario uh
handed down yeah and
i just everyone got [ __ ]
married before me there was a ring that
was supposed to be mine but i gave it to
my brother really that's nice of you you
never thanked me but it's okay i always
joke with his with his wife i always go
oh you can keep it well annie we want
you to get the diamond you want i've
been looking at them it's i my diamond
tastes are more basic than i thought
explain like i really like a pear shape
i didn't realize i would like i just
like really cute looks like a little
teardrop like we did see one that was
really cute i don't know if i want like
gold
or silver because i wear more gold but
silver i think looks better i don't know
i think i see you just platinum just to
keep it simple yeah because that i think
that's the one metal where it's like it
can take a lot of abuse
i just like things that i can destroy
and then they won't be destroyed
like friendships
[Laughter]
but it will never go anywhere
it will never leave you
um we um
the kind of i am the engagement ring
that i have in my mind is a little bit
like more complex that's why we i
befriended nick potash yeah from maui
he's an amazing jewelry that's why
that's why
nick we're being transparent here
send us the send us the jewelry nick
we had fun with you we like you know we
love you so much brought us such good
snacks they were so thoughtful he was so
cool wait i love him he's still a friend
like this is this is why i love
i don't like there aren't a lot of fans
or people that i meet like after shows
or whatnot that truly become like i've
become bonded to and real good friends
with but when they do when it happens it
is like a lifelong friendship i feel
that way about this girl named dorothy
who was the first girl to ever come to
we had a live show tiger belly did there
was like 20 people and she was one of
them and she's a huge she was a huge fan
of you esther she actually found us
through you oh my god and um
now she is somebody that i just adore
um don't you wish you said j wolf i was
just going to say i have a list jay
wolfe jeff i know you've got some jazz
cheers
donut
but i just feel like there's this extra
layer of like goodness in that
friendship like even when i how i feel
about like nick and stuff like he's
somebody that likes
but um one of my one of my great fans
texted me and wished was said he hoped i
was doing better my friend phil who's
been he was so cool because i was
getting so because when i first my first
fans were from when i did opi and
anthony so they were so mean because
that was just like the culture like they
were just trying to get your attention
that way
but phil was nice he was nice go pack
phil
um and he um so he just i got him in a
moon tower he watched he came to chelsea
lately and got to watch my taping
like he's the man it's so much fun yeah
when it works like when it's safe
yeah and when it's not safe
that you guys bringing up that guy
though nick from
hawaii um when he i'll never forget the
moment after we did that museum tour
where he gave us all something he gave
me weed and then i saw in the car ahead
and he's saying where's the weed and he
pointed at me i couldn't have any just
who doesn't smoke she just looked at me
like this
and i was like i'm sorry i've never been
so scared i'm ready to give it up
good i trained you well it took 13 years
to get this reaction
no i knew you weren't going to smoke it
you didn't smoke them no i know i
totally didn't but i was like and if
we're in separate cars i'm like i got no
weed trust that it wasn't at you it was
my own addiction i was like i don't know
i love that i was like we have no weed
nick where's the [ __ ] weed i started
yelling at nick where the [ __ ] the
weed
i think i am ready to um smoke with you
guys i'm there i quit smoking weed but
i'll smoke oh [ __ ] no i don't want to
bring you back in no i think i cannot i
can i can do sleepover yeah well here's
the thing i just had to do it the last
the last two weeks have just been
just i'm so [ __ ] exhausted and i
think it is at a point where i should
pick up an addiction at this point yes
it's one actor's like kissing my [ __ ]
no
elsa when you found remember when i
first told you guys or bobby and i you
know like talk to you guys about like or
when you found out that we were in an
open relationship were you kind of like
i just found out today
were you like kind of like
oh [ __ ] can i get in there okay i
actually have a theory that you think
that okay because i remember texting you
once randomly just being like i'm super
horny
and like and then i felt like
i've never
not
had fomo before except this moment i
just i'm so glad you never texted me
that this was
and i remember being like oh wait like
this is weird timing on my part like
does she think i was like asking for
something like you know you did you you
were like you me and carlos then were
like looking at um different
available sex workers yeah women
that could potentially
you know that i could have yeah you know
well because there was a moment where
you guys were gonna
have a third right right right
right you and carlos
yes
of course they were interviewing me in
that role
oh you guys i never care i was just
whatever whatever you want whatever you
want in your life i support i know
whatever makes you happy i am supportive
of
yeah it's not hurting anyone and you're
not so thank you so much for just
continually being here week to week hell
yeah for loving us just as we are
um for loving us in our most imperfect
ways
for rallying behind us yeah for
defending us
just overall just being the [ __ ] best
slugs three girls could ask for we love
you guys and we'll see you next week
[Music]
you